didn't y'all get married right in the
back we got married right outside that
door
right what do you remember from that day
i just remember waking up and
being very anxious because i was getting
married
i remember the way you looked at me when
the doors opened
it was like you caught your breath and
you were like
yes uh that moment it was
breathtaking yeah yeah i'd never seen it
like that before
no no maybe
and now the doors came open and chaka
khan ain't nobody
was playing and i took one look across
the pool and i said
i'm coming to marry you and
just the look on her face it was almost
like we had 24
guests everybody disappeared and i only
saw her
wow it was the perfect day yeah
yeah perfect now we fast forward to
being the advocates champions of pride
what does that mean to you
honor we're on the cover of the advocate
i mean this is did you see
my cheeks hurt because i can't stop
smiling i feel
those are the exact words very very
honored
i feel like you are someone that people
trust and love you feel like
family so it's important when you push
something forward
i think people listen and do you feel
that responsibility
you know i don't know about
responsibility but i do feel an
overwhelming sense of being welcomed
you know what i mean i was always
a friend of the community i was always
community adjacent i was always an
advocate see what i did there for the
community
and now i'm an actual member i'm a card
carrying member
house family and all the kids and how
are they doing and how how are they how
do they feel about all
the kids are doing great um admittedly
they sometimes come here
just to see her and not me oh really
it's like
is it like that yeah they walk in the
door half now yes
i have a better half and they walk in
the door and it's like where's jess
and i'm like oh you know hello i'm here
too
but they have their own relationship
outside of
us which i love as well how do you
handle
someone like nicey and what i mean is
when i say handle i mean that in the
best
sort of way i totally get it um patience
yeah patient
patience patience because she is
absolutely hilarious and so
i find myself in certain instances and
moments that
you know i'm just like wow you know i
try to balance it all you know cause
it's a lot it's a lot i'm a lot
yes yes
lisa called this a love shack explain
that lots of love
cuddling laughing impatience
we spent a lot of time you know we we
fell in love here
um we spent a lot of time together
during quarantine
so we've had many dates all around the
house we find little areas to curate
special moments so that's why i call it
a love shack
because you know we are constantly
probably at least four or five times a
week it's like
can you meet me by the pool can you meet
me in the movie room can you meet me in
the bathtub
so we we find little spaces to date
around here
can you meet me in the bathtub i didn't
flip through
nothing slipped through is there going
to be another book now
will you write another book you know who
told me to write another book
who oprah we had a very
loving heart to heart and she said dear
i know you think the first book is the
book but this
is the book so when oprah tells you it's
the book you just get out your pen and
your paper and you figure
it out so there's a book coming there's
a book coming
what do you think people need to know i
don't know about what they
need to know but so many people what do
you want to share
well people are very curious about my
journey yes and how did you go
from way over here to leia
oh and there is a process in all of that
and
that's where it will live in the book
you two were friends though you started
as friends and you're great
forever yeah don't tell me about that
jerry we were
really really good friends and i loved
her as a person
there was no doubt about that she loved
me too but i
never thought about a relationship with
her or any other woman for that matter
of a fact
and then after i was divorced i don't
know what happened i looked at her one
day and my eyes crossed and i said who
are you hey can you sit and stay wow
jessica is this what like happiness is
this your picture of happiness
absolutely absolutely yes and i'm
basking every moment that we're together
because happiness definitely is
something that comes from within you
know you have to be happy
with yourself first but you know
sharing it with somebody else it's
it's really really really really really
cool what was the journey like for you
i mean i'm a musician so it was playing
music every day and
and feeling so much passion for what i
do and what i was doing
and then after meeting her and i gained
a new passion
for acting and some of the other
dimensions that i started playing around
in
and i don't know it was like a 360 you
know in terms of my journey with her
because
we were friends very good friends
and then we weren't and i
but i've never been with anyone who i
was friends with first
i always start at the loving part and
then back into the friendship and this
is my first time having the friendship
first
and then a relationship and it is so
much richer and so much deeper that's
what i was going to ask you
is it a huge difference because for me
you're on this
level already where y'all are cool
you'll want to be around each other
right oh yeah
until until we were around each other
and i you could feel the energy
it was palpable it was like this is
something different
i've never been around you and felt this
and let me tell you what i did
put on my tennis shoes barrel i was out
of there
i was out of there i got so nervous
because i felt like
what if i do something and i lose the
friendship
and i never want to be without this soul
ever
and i was like and maybe maybe this was
a mistake
and what if we mess it up and then we
can't be friends anymore
so then i just disappeared she did
she did wait a minute and what did you
do i
started texting her and i started you
know because she was reluctant
and i started chasing her and now i'm
texting her good morning
good afternoon no response i hope you
had a great evening
no response so
how long did it take and what did it
take it took a minute but it just really
i just had to
trust the foundation enough to know that
even if we stepped into this water we
could always come back
to to to ground zero with that being our
friendship
so you know and that had to be
understood you know it took
you know understanding that the
friendship would definitely be
maintained you know
so yeah what do you think this advocate
story and cover means jessica as far as
people now sitting back and saying i
mean people love nisi no matter what and
there's not like it's like
oh nisi different no it's like it's
nicey no matter what but how important
is this advocate
cover the advocate cover is important
because it definitely represents
love uh pride is love it is it's passion
it is courage uh and she represents all
those things you know
she's very courageous uh very talented
and smart so i think that
it just represents that you know just
trying something
you know i'm just happy to be here with
her to express and and show our love
to people that inspires people y'all
could have
had this wedding kept it secret live you
know lived your life here and done your
thing
but you chose not to and you continue to
be an advocate yes and
what have you heard but it's been the
feedback as you've been an advocate
well since i'm i'm new to the community
but i will tell you that since i got
here
we have received the warmest welcome
ever
um and there's so much support so much
love
and i i mean i love it here now i don't
know everything yet you know what i mean
this will be my first pride
so i'm looking forward to all the things
i don't even know what the things are
but i want to be at all the things can
somebody so is this camera on me can
somebody invite us to the things
i want to come to the theme yeah well
probably you should be grand marshall
well i mean i don't even know i didn't
even know they had that but if they
asked me to do it
you would do it oh would i do it yes
what would i have to do
yes wear a nice outfit and wave to the p
i don't know what i have to do but i'm
looking forward to
the um i'm just looking forward to
fellowshipping with people who are
walking in their truth
you know that's just a beautiful place
to be in to wake up every day and not
have to live a lie as a gift
so i i'm looking forward to celebrating
people
um with that header you know and do you
see people moving forward do you see
people pushing forward because i feel
like
the world is changing it has changed
since last year
but do you see people moving forward oh
for sure
for sure for sure i mean you know
and i hope that we can be a part of it
nisi
there you sign a deal with cbs is there
anything going on with that
is there anything going on
oh well um you know
they were looking for someone
to take a dive into the world of talk
yes and you can talk and i said well
where's the microphone
so um that's the path that we're we're
going down right now is
is talk what is an easy talk show like
oh
honey what isn't it life you know what i
mean
it's fun it's funny it's relatable
it has takeaway you laugh you cry you
know
cleavage is always on deck you know how
i do
and will jessica will you be a part of
it will family be a part of it
well i begged so we'll see i mean you
know what i mean
she got her own thing going but i was
like could you please would you please
would you be my neighbor
but i've asked her you know if there is
a space in the place if she would come
i love when we can work together in our
art
intersex so that would be absolutely
delicious if she has time for me i mean
you know we just have time for you to
come on jessica
would you be a part of it absolutely
well it
in terms of what the uh elements would
be absolutely like live band a musician
you know because i that's what i'm
talking about yeah so absolutely of
course
that is how our art we're intersex oh
i feel like i got a little sneak peek
into what happened if i'm lucky that's
what
will happen we'll see we'll see
what kind of deal needs to need to cut
with you to get you to be there
now that we can't tell you now that i'm
not going to say
um but you know what it is